Anh ở đâu đây?
Em...
Hôm nay mình đang bên đây
Hôm nay mình đến đây nhìn
Về trẻ sắp chuyển
Bên... bên nơi
12 tháng
Sau là
Bên... bên trường bình
Kinh tình...
Ngày hôm nay trường mới 3 tuổi yêu
Trường sau...
Anh đến đây 29 hả?
Đúng đấy!
Đã không hẳn bệnh, hành truyền giống như vư yếu
Ừa
Nhưng mà xong lúc có cửa truyền
Đây là hành truyền giống như một bộ hành truyền
Thì thường những ngày đấy đối chức ngành
Nhưng mà đối chức hành truyền
Không phát vì phân độ thì thì có cái ngày truyền không phân độ
Vâng
Vì nên vư yếu là cái ngày truyền giống như kia
Với 29 hả?
Vâng, với 29
Hôm đấy là tuần sau, lúc 7 tuần sau của nhóm mình
Thường là ngày gian truyền giống như hành truyền
Vì có hoạt động tức là dành xuất bình chân ngày này là từ năm năm vào ngày xưa là có rất nhiều hoạt động xuất nổi.
Trước là cái đại tế thẳng, nghệ tế, hoạt động tức là dành xuất bình chân ngày này là từ năm năm vào ngày xưa là có rất nhiều hoạt động xuất nổi.